قال رئيس الاوكراني
الوضع في مدينه سوليدار شرقيا البلاد بات
صعبا للغايه لكنها لا تزال صامده مع مدينه
محمود رغم الغارات الروسيه التي الحقت
بهما دمار كبيره واضاف زنسكي ان القتال
العنيفه متواصل وان مدينه خرسون تتعرض
لقصف الروسيه بالذخيره الحارقه
لم يتغير كثيرا خلال الاسبوع الاول من
العام الجديد يستمر القتال العنيف في
منطقتين لوجان
رغم الغارات الروسيه التي دمرت معظم
المدينه سوليدار ايضا صامده رغم الدمار
الكبير الذي لحق بها في كل مكان بالقرب من
باخ موت وسوليدار يفقد المحتلون حياتهم من
اجل تنفيذ الافكار المجنونه لقاده النظام
الروسي قصفت روسيا مدينه خرسون للذخيره
الحارقه بعد عيد الميلاد ويستهدفت مواقع
مدنيه في اكرامي تورس ومدن اخرى في دون
باس تحديدا عندما اعلنت عن وقفه اطلاق
النار
الروسيه ونتيجه مباشره لعدوان روسيا على
بلاده اضافها بدنياك في مقابله تلفزيونيه
اوكرانيا لها الحق الكامل في استهداف
الروس في شبه جزيره القرد
مياه
وفقا للقانون الدولي فان من حقنا تدمر كل
المواقع الروسيه على اراضينا بما في ذلك
شبه جزيره القرم المحتله حلفاءنا ايضا لا
يشككون في حقنا بذلك اما استهداف العمق
الروسي كالمطارات العسكريه فهو نتيجه
مباشره للعدوان على بلادنا اننا نشهد
اليوم انهيار روسيا داخليا وهذا الانهيار
سوف يتضخم ويتطور الى اعمال مقاومه في
الداخل الروسي النفسيه في روسيا توجد
الكثير من الصراعات الداخليه في بكتيريا
والشيشان
الجنوبيه هذه الصراعات ستتفاقم بسبب
الهزائم على ساحه المعركه الاوكرانيه
وتصدع هيكله نظام الروسي